science and technology is a vast ocean
and is filled with mysteries theories
innovations and inventions
in this modern era each day we come up
with new inventions
due to its need and demand
such inventions include the modern
industry booming technologies like nfts
cloud services virtual reality and many
more
so in today's video we will cover the
best of the top vr headsets available in
2022 by simply learn
so with a warm welcome let's get started
in modern days the need for new
technologies and innovations is at a
great demand and the need is at its
maximum
to minimize human efforts and enhance
productivity such technologies include
cryptocurrencies cloud computing
artificial intelligence robotics and
many more
people are now heading towards the
virtual world
technologies which make no difference be
like the physical one
and thus reality technologies come into
life
as part of today's video
at first we will have a quick intro on
what is ar technology
and what is a vr headset
and what is the need for a vr headset
moving further
we will understand
best vr headsets in 2022 and at the end
we will conclude this video
so
first let's discuss what vr is
vr or virtual reality is a 360 degree
simulated environment composed of motion
sensors graphics and animations for a
specific purpose it enhances the user
experience to the next level with no
change in overall aspects
so now that we know what vr is let's
understand what is a vr headset in
simple words the device used to
experience virtual reality technology is
known as vr headsets in other words a vr
headset is a device composed of a
display stereo sound and head motion
tracking sensors to provide virtual
experience in a 360 degree view
some vr headsets also support the
features of eye tracking and gaming
controllers for a better user experience
so as we all
know what is via headset now let's look
at some of the common or familiar
headsets that include
sony's playstation vr the first
headset with the oled screen and a 120
hertz refresh rate with 3d audio
technology
second is oculus quest 2 by meta
a two in one vr headset that functions
both as a standalone and a pcvr headset
third is
hp reverb g2 a 2 kvr headset compact and
design headset as more comfortable and
convenient to use
then we have htc vive pro
a 4k vr headset with a 120 hertz refresh
rate and stunning visuals up to 120
degree field
of view
and then we have samsung's gear vr or
lightweight headset with a 101 degree
field of stunning visuals with 1000 plus
apps and games
so as we have already discussed what is
vr technology and vr headset
now let's get into what is the need for
vr headset
vr enhances the user experience to the
next level by use of vr headset and
controllers which provide an immersive
and interactive experience to the user
second is
dr is assimilated and at the same time
acts as a risk-free environment where
the control lies on the user's hand
vr is accessible in multiple platforms
with self-controlled environment where
users can control the overall activity
and for this vr is virtual private and
design environment for a specific use
so how to choose a vr headset
as we know about vr headset let's have a
look on how to choose a vr headset
so whether you go from a standalone
headset or a pc
vr here are some prerequisites as the
first one is
ram
for a better game play and productivity
it's always better to have a minimum of
8gb ram in a dual channel module
then we have processor the processor or
cpu is the brain of a computer which
performs all the computational
operations
it is always best to go for intel's i5
processor or amd's fx8350
or equivalent or creator for better
performance and power consumption
moving towards graphics card
these days graphics card are quite
scarce and unavailable due to factors
like silicon sword shortage or chip
shortage and at the same time there is a
maximum price in graphics card talking
about graphics card for vr there is a
need for a minimum of
nvidia geforce gtx 970
or amd radeon r9 290 equivalent or
greater
next we have input output ports
to talk about input output a minimum of
hdmi 1.4 or displayport of 1.2 is
required
and at last a higher speed internet for
online or stream
games so
how to choose exactly a vr headset till
now we saw the prerequisites of vr
now let's see the key factors of
choosing a vr headset
platform however most of all common vrt
headsets have cross platform access
second is type of vr it depends on the
user to access contents via pc vr or
standalone vr
display frequency commonly known as
refresh rate
a good refresh ranges from 60 as the
minimum to a maximum of 120 hertz
tracking system tracks your movements
for a better immersive experience which
includes external sensors cameras and
others
then we have controllers
depending on the headphones controllers
may also differ commonly controllers are
designed in dof or degree of freedom in
two categories
three dof that provides 360 degree
rotational freedom and the other is 6dof
that provides rotational and positional
freedom
which includes triggers trackpads
buttons and so on
then we have field of view or fov it is
the width of the image expressed in
degrees for comparison that of the human
is between 100 and 110 the wider the
view
the higher the emotion impression
and then we have support
new technology requires special skills
and knowledge and assistance on these
technologies
so now let's come into the best vr
headsets in 2022
oculus quest 2
commonly known as the best and the
leading affordable vr headset with a
cable free headset
wide library of games and a flexible
setup
it also eliminates the need of an
expensive gaming pc
as it is both standalone and tethering
enables makes it stand unique among
others
then we have hp reverb g2
the best windows
vr headset with a great 4k resolution
and quite affordable one with 90 hertz
of refresh rate and similar to a plug
and play device which is compatible with
windows 10 and windows 11 os with an fov
of 114 degrees
on third we have valve index known as
the premium vr headset with touch
sensitive sensors 120 hertz refresh rate
and tether vr headset with wide field of
view of 130 degrees
htc vive pro known as the best high
resolution
vr with excellent performance and a 4k
display with a wide library of games and
a fov of 120 degrees
then we have playstation vr playstation
vr is a tethered headset with 120hz
refresh rate with the oled screen
accessible in playstation 4 and ps5
so now we have reached the end of this
video
in this video we have discussed about
what is vr technology vr headset and the
need for vr headset in addition we also
had a brief introduction on the top five
of the best vr headsets available in
2022 and also a guide to choose the best
vr headsets across the available ones
i hope you enjoyed this video post your
questions and feedback
in the comment section below make sure
to like this video and subscribe to my
channel simply done hit the bell icon
for instant notifications for more
interesting and informative videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here